the only reason I get to talk to you
guys and be a tiff is because I
partnered up with health of Aurora which
is why where we're at so I want to give
a huge thank you to House of Aurora for
helping me support movies and getting
Collider to TIFF as you know it's you
know expensive to come to film festivals
and put this whole thing on I just want
to say thank you to them
for the two of you jumping right on in
we're at the Toronto Film Festival
my favorite Film Festival maybe I'm
biased but what what does it mean to be
a part of this fast with your movie well
this is the the North American premiere
of of Masayo we've we've screened it at
the Berlin Film Festival early in the
year but this is the first time that
it's coming to this side of the world so
it yeah I mean we're very excited to to
see what American audiences think about
it you know and and then it'll start
making its way down actually like
literally we start here then we go to
New York and then and then to Mexico and
then to South America so there's a nice
journey that the film will have so this
is the starting point and also just the
festival itself is a great window to
search for films you know you you're
screening alongside other amazing
filmmaker so I'm happy to be here yeah
delighted we I mean something this movie
it's always nice to see what happens
when a film comes out and here there's
people from all over the world I mean
also the the film gets an awareness and
other parts of the world where it's
gonna come out soon and everything and
eventually it'll come out worldwide and
I'm not just accused I mean it's nice to
experience this like firsthand you know
I would I would love to be in other
festivals as well afterwards to see what
people react I asked him to narrate
questions but no one almost everyone
seeing this interview will not have seen
the movie yet so could you talk a little
bit about what it's about
yeah well Messiah is based on
the real story of heist that happened in
1985 where two college dropouts entered
the National Anthropology Museum in
Mexico City
on a Christmas Eve and stole 150 pieces
of pre-hispanic art maíam gnostic
mystical and so and you know the
following day it was reported as heist
perpetrated by a band of experts
international art dealers connected to
our art thefts in Paris and London and
wherever and it turned out when they
finally caught him that it was two guys
who had done a prank kind of a kind of
prank that that got out of hand the film
tells the story of these two friends
just before they commit this robbery and
then follows them as they kind of the
downward spiral of their own morality
and sanity you know as as to after the
theft but for you what was it
how did you first hear about the project
was it something that you you know is
there a text message are you actually
getting the script and saying oh wow
this is a crazy story no it was actually
a conversation with with alone so let's
talk about this movie that I wanna make
and stuff we made up known and they and
he told me about it
he showed me look no no no what is it
called like yeah like yeah like a little
presentation stuff and the script was
still in the words you know one still
but I was already
I was already in just the fact and it
was exciting more like from the
beginning
and I was ya interested by it and then I
don't know I say this a lot but I really
mean it it's like we fall in love like
you never depend on remember when when
it all started like you can't like to
mention that moment because it's just
part of I mean you all of sudden become
part of that no one and part of your
life and film became part of our lives
yeah so everything about it I was
interested in I'm curious from when you
first when the idea first germinated to
what people are seeing on screen how
much changed along the way a lot I mean
this is this is a film that that has had
a really long journey my co-writer
Manuel Alcala started he's the son of a
news reporter and so he has this like he
has it in love this investigative side
and she started researching the the case
about 10 years ago and start he started
developing a script and then after he
saw my first movie he said well I want
you to direct this and and and then I
started working on the script with him
we started rewriting and and then you
know it started taking its own life you
know it started we started sort of
deciding what to get rid of and what
things from the real case to keep so
yeah it's been a long journey how
involved are you I'm curious as an actor
um I don't offer you in the do you like
being in the editing room and how much
are you sort of like when you step off
set I don't want to see it till you have
like the director's cut done oh no and
when I'm gonna throw a monocular I don't
I don't get involved at all in the the
editing room at all like a it is always
a surprise it is always say I know I'm
always curious to see it you know Uncle
Mo is cute too but I never I would never
do that I think to go into an editing
woman and work on the you know I like
what Moe is cursed because obviously let
me
these people that move well there's
definitely people that yeah but no we
also we come from a very different way
of working I mean as well the reserve we
have the ability and possibilities to do
whatever we want you know in the fact
that we're we don't have to cater for
any studio or anything you know we're
doing our film the way we want it like
and we're all also you know in the know
that we are interpreting a director's
point of view so we are all at the
service of Alphonsus point there's also
like valances Punto point of view were
like interpreting is point of view in a
way and and and it's a collaboration but
at the end of the day it's his point of
view that will give way will make the
film a film totally but have you ever
seen like the cut and been like I know I
delivered a different take that I really
liked in that scene was talk about that
no no I don't know would talk about
about I mean about what they think of
the cops
sure I think of like there are other
possibilities and stuff but I never know
know you don't even know like yeah I
understand what you mean but I'd never
felt that like I've never felt like I
didn't do that like I don't know because
so you don't know what the hell's going
on wonder when you've being shot you
know when you bring the cameras on you
like you might feel what certain way and
you just know what the camera sees
something else completely I want you
feeling so yeah and you know that from
when you direct like different processes
so I think that's very clear I'm always
curious who did you show the film to
early on to try to get honest feedback
and how did the film change as a result
of that feedback well I've kind of the
first my first movie I showed it to too
many people I think so and I you you can
get a little bit lost if you have too
many opinions so this time me and
I interview very carefully like let's
just show it to our handful of people
that you know that I really trust so a
couple of I feeling maker friends of
colleagues the one person that I have a
sort of mental relationship I guess or
like well at least I really admire his
work and is a bubbly public offski the
polish director
I sent him a little like he's the only
persistent yeah external guy who saw the
film and sent me some really useful
comments yeah but but I think that that
that's a natural process you know like
you you write the movie three times so
the third time you write it in the
editing room is it's a journey of
discovery and you have to I mean I think
that's that's a normal process so it's
not so much what what people said to us
is it was just guided by our intuition
of finding the final film and also once
the film's of like the film is the film
you know like once it yeah then it comes
to subjective we might like it might not
and that's that's where you know there's
not nothing else added whatever people
would say no later it's the thing of
like it's just to see if and then that
way that we so careful to know who to
talk to when showing a film like it
can't just be like no because some
people are very good at giving advice of
like working the film making the film
work of what you want I don't know it's
a it's an interesting process that
fortunately nobody can teach because if
they would teach them it would format
something that is very I don't know it's
very unique or if every film and every
context person I don't know it's it's
it's it's strange but but also I mean
what's nice is that the in Mexico we
have a culture I'd say or tradition
maybe of collaboration yeah of showing
each other's films and and working with
each other helping out each other you
know there is that
we inherited that from from us directors
that really worked with each other you
know and they helped each other to make
the films better yeah no I think that's
a crucial part of the process like
choosing the two or three people that
can really see the film that you're
trying to make and then you point point
two towards your own direction not
towards the film that they would do no
no that there's a handful of people that
can do that only I think I'd have that
vision is saying this is not I wouldn't
make this movie like this but you're
trying to get to here so I think you're
missing this and that for Egypt for each
of you memorable moments from filming
what's like a day or two that you will
remember forever oh there was so many in
this film but really a big number man so
lucky go in like yeah hey working in the
anthropology museum not sure like being
you know having the Anthropology Museum
in Mexico open for us at night and there
was a moment where were the restrictions
were we couldn't get the camera inside
the holes there's we could be outside
you know the camera could be outside
though we could be inside the actors
know so and you showed us like you put
the camera like walking around and
spending some time alone in the Aztec
Hall for example yeah that was beautiful
we were there me and the other actor and
and an assistant production assistant we
were there like I don't know maybe an
hour on their own like just in the in
the hall for our own you know facing the
big Aztec calendar you know and you know
just spending some time and one of the
most important places in the world of
human history I don't know it just felt
like me but he's like what at what
what's that going on you know what I
mean this is why you paid to be in the
movie
I felt that at in in Palenque mm-hm
when we went to the Mayan ruins of
Palenque and yeah we were so lucky to be
able to film and those pyramids yeah
by the way that footage is exceptional
when I was watching it in the film I was
like this is Brett like breathtaking
ya know that place is yeah it's magical
and being there without tourists you
know they would only let us shoot after
tourists had left so that was like you
start shooting at Magic Hour and then so
one night we went on shooting into the
night
and just being there and when I remember
when this sound this sound girl who's a
really good friend she was doing the
heart on room room tone sorry her room
tone and you know this everyone be quiet
and she reached he did a really long
ringtone we did like five or ten minutes
of everyone silent we just laid back in
the pyramids just listened to the jungle
and it was just like that was the
favorite moment five-five everyone has
been coming in the studio
we've been playing something called get
to know your tip at tenbi I promise this
is painless and hopefully you will find
it at least semi okay what TV show would
you love to guest spot on and what TV
show would you love to guest direct from
communities from life
some people are keeping it modern like I
want to be on I never thought about this
one you know what I'd say I mean I would
have loved me the wire jerk even though
it's maybe a boring answer but I think
I've heard the wire many times but it's
just a testament of how incredible that
show is yeah
that much of an impact on so many actors
and people you know I would say that
Flying Circus like multiforms it just
whatever just being a sound person or on
that set or whatever you do you have a
favorite sci-fi or fantasy film it's not
my genre but I remember I used to love
that labyrinth yeah just 2001 the couch
and yes what scared you has a good film
scared you as a kid the Michael Jackson
Thriller video like hell like because
they used to pass it in Mexico after
they show the song for kids to go to
sleep it would like to see you know like
good night kids good night no
programming is gonna begin to another
like yeah I'm going crazy like scared as
hell with those eyes you know the living
is so scared I remember Robocop and like
really scared me because my brother kind
of tortured me with it's like playing
over and over that when they kill Murphy
and just a bullet going to his head like
he would rewind it and play it again or
like please stop and she would do it
more and more yeah that scared me is
there anything that you collect a
inadvertently I've now realized that
I've been collecting books okay yeah
books and records I love
do you own any movie or TV show props
just me yeah the ones opinion do you
borrow them from the set or do you know
you ask if I can take it home and they
tell me okay sometimes I mean for
example with Moo say I have a little bit
to look figures it's a little a little
ring with a cot the one that flies yeah
I kept a key that do you have anything
remember
what TV show have you watched all the
way through more than once if you have
no the Flying Circus yeah and The
Sopranos I guess the Sopranos I really
like this excellent show what's the
background photo on your phone my kids
my wife is there a movie that you've
watched more than 20 times yeah more
than how many times look at the like a
million times no no Z's that you've
watched like you know 50 times or 40
times like something that you have
watched the most in so many because I
mean when I was a kid because it was the
mouth this era of bedtime VHS so people
would like you know they would only have
one term to see like all the time
repeated occasions but um but I mean
with my kids I see all the movies for
kids
oh yeah I watched I think not on weald
is the film that I've seen once in my
life which one ratatouille oh yeah I
think is the film that is the most
because they watch it over and over and
I loved watching it with them and I
loved learning from that movie also
because it's it's such a good cinema you
know it's amazing so it has the best
ending you know yeah
no spoilers know by now most people have
seen it but the ending is it gets me
every single time
yeah probably Life of Brian I think
we've discovered a Monty Python
and and a Marquart the other Fellini and
McCoys and I don't know probably
something like Ferris Bueller's Day Off
or something I remember those in the Big
Lebowski
I think I've seen that big lebowski like
many and the Mel Brooks comedies know
Blazing Saddles history of the world
legacy yeah that one I remember somebody
having ageism and they would be left it
at my house and I think it was laughs at
family and I didn't have it compete you
know it was like yeah some members of
the ending my last question for you guys
do you remember what it was when you
were growing up that inspired or helped
you want to be in the entertainment
industry to want to make movies to want
to act in direct well we've interesting
to narrow it down to films because in a
way I mean because that's what we're
here for
but I mean cuz I and my parents are
actors so in a way I had to I wanted not
to be an actor for a long long time so
there was never a moment of guess I want
to be that you know and and and actually
until now I know it happens to some
people for me I've never experienced
this thing of watching a film and
thinking oh I would have loved to be in
that or I've done that I have that
feeling only in theatre when I see a
play and I go like oh I would love to be
there like playing football with them
you know like I would love to be you
know they're like just that experience I
would love to live it with some time I'm
very very good recipient of films I love
watching them and I go wow and he's like
an I didn't really know like encouraged
you know I don't know it does feel so
there was never you know it's it's crazy
it's like I think it wasn't for my third
movie that I decided I wanted to work in
films yeah that's crazy
the third time I was in I was like okay
I think I think I like I said not
getting into it but I I yeah it was
later it was later it wasn't I was doing
shows if in fact you mind
for me I guess it was different because
my parents are doctors so I wanted not
to be a doctor
uh-huh yeah so I did a lot of drama at
school and that kind of led to that but
I remember when I saw who framed roger
rabbit that film I saw a little bit the
other day I remembered like that really
stayed with me when I when I left the
cinema I asked my mom like who made that
like I realized that there was somebody
that made the thing you know the the
before that I just films just existed
but that was the first time I thought
there was somebody behind the camera and
wow how smart they were yeah what's
amazing about Roger Rabbit when you
think back is that was made in the 80s
before the advent of you know what CGI
can do so so much of that is done
practically on set it's it's it's
amazing yeah you know when you when you
when you study it and you examine you
know it's and what Bob Hoskins did you
know it's it's just a great performance
I mean it's necessarily congratulations
on your movie I hope everyone seeks it
out because it's a effin crazy story and
it's like beautiful look at thank you
again for coming in and you really have
a fantastic TIFF they do you think you
do
[Music]